[Music]
earlier this week we showed you the cast
of Will & Grace back to work on the set
now this show doesn't return to NBC
until next months but it's already been
renewed for another season we talked to
those tight-knit co-stars about shooting
again after 10 years off air it's it's a
little crazy because of our age then I'm
not even sure we're gonna be alive today
is the first official day of rehearsals
it's a closed set just Shawn Eric
Deborah and Megan gettin to have fun all
I can say is my first line is
I had the craziest dream it has been
over a decade since you guys have been
filming regularly together so I need to
know who's most likely to laughter in
the middle of a tape Deborah I'm gonna
say Shawn but that would be me steal
something from wardrobe Oh Debra
Messing's practical joker on set Shawn
Shawn yeah probably
Eric probably Eric Eric or Meg yeah
who's singing the most in between takes
yeah totally Eric singing all the time
and it's lovely here in a sitcom sized
up
and Megan and Deborah we all kind of
sang have a musical episode I think we
should know that grace loves to sing up
a little bit it's been a little long
look what you just got America a little
sneak peek not only on et oh me too
[Music]